quantumania required over 1 000 VFX
artists working on over 800 shots to
build an entirely subatomic world in the
quantum realm but Marvel's decision to
put more money behind black panther
wakanda forever may just have cost them
in the long run this is what Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania looks like without
VFX Corey Stoll is back and this time he
has an entirely new look
Corey admitted that filming for Modoc
could sometimes be a pain dots on your
face and you have his camera and you
don't really know what you're going to
look like but at the same time in some
ways the ideal way to act Corey didn't
have to wait around for lights camera or
even hair and makeup he just had to
strap on the head mounted camera and was
ready
the VFX artists who worked on Modoc
weren't quite as Carefree though they
had to deal with some pretty long
working hours and the studio taking a
number of shortcuts and on top of that
they struggled to nail modoc's design
they wanted to make sure that you could
still tell it was Cory's face and so
they had to be careful with how much
they stretched his features because you
can lose Corey really quickly let's dive
a little deeper into the issues the VFX
team faced shall we one VFX artist who
preferred to remain anonymous said that
it was impossible for them to carry
Ant-Man all the way through because all
the money and all the best resources had
been given the Black Panther wakanda
forever which Marvel had apparently
considered to be top priority now the
team on quantumania was left scrambling
to make a bunch of last minute changes
that caused tension turmoil and weight
on set and artists would sometimes have
to work 80 hours per week for months in
order to meet deadlines it's clear that
plenty of shortcuts were being taken too
it wasn't on common for the VFX artists
to have to digitally recreate an entire
actor in a shot which often left the
artists wondering why didn't they film
it the right way or how they wanted it
in the first place all in all there's
definitely a reason why the special
effects have been getting the sort of
reviews they have even though they
created an entire subatomic world the
quantum realm really is a world unto
itself sort of like our channel is so
why don't you take a second now to just
hit that subscribe button anyway back to
the quantum realm director Peyton Reed
said that we didn't want it to be too CG
heavy but we aren't entirely sure it
worked out that way considering the
entire world is basically CGI four MPC
teams were needed to put together the
quantum realm which turned out to be an
entire microverse spanning 40 kilometers
in diameter and including 20 kilometers
of quantum Skies that's a pretty big
microburst and if you look up at the
skies you'll be able to find a number of
special effects such as slow moving
portals noise waves stars and clouds
wanted to be as big and as visceral and
consuming as possible our actors would
usually be placed in front of a blue
screen so that the quantum realm could
be added in around them afterwards
although there were times in filming
that the cast actually was submerged
within the world Peyton Reed became
familiar with volume technology while
working on the Mandalorian all of this
is just LED screen displaying
backgrounds pre-made in a video game
engine this technology allows the actor
to better imagine that they're actually
in scene easier than if they were acting
in front of a green screen imagining how
VFX artists would make this planet look
once filming had ended for quantumania
Peyton knew it would be be important to
render the quantum realm vividly and yet
he wasn't sure that the volume
technology was ready for it especially
because he wanted a lot of movement
within those screens in the end they
ended up using the volume technology and
although Payton admitted that it was
great for certain environments he said
that it was not necessarily right for
other ones sometimes the sets were far
too big for the volume and so they had
to use partial sets I didn't know he
could do that still the actors loved the
volume because they got to get a bit of
an idea as to how these environments
would look in the movie Let's Take a
closer look at everything that our MPC
teams had to build the artists of MPC
Montreal were responsible for not only
one but two large-scale CG environments
the gorilla Village and chronopolis both
of which required them to put together
full-scale battle sequences along with
CG crowds an army of battlelands and
hundreds of VFX elements to be added to
the plate NPC Adelaide put together
Janet's Homestead by filling a library
with plenty of highly detailed CG
foliage to help add a sense of depth and
layers to the environment the creatures
in the film also come courtesy of our
MPC teams everything from the hundreds
of battlelands to the snail-like horses
known as norces you can clearly see that
our VFX teams had a lot to handle and
yet the most challenging part of the
whole thing was putting together the
blight which had to be the cause of some
pretty large-scale destruction but even
something as seemingly straightforward
as a prison break can have its problems
in a movie like this have you heard
about the monsters aliens robot zombies
they're a Canadian VFX team better known
by the acronym Mars who actually had the
privilege of working on a few scenes for
quantumania they offered their use of
vanity AI on a few scenes but their
biggest and probably most flashy scene
was when Cassie broke gen Torah out of
prison a moment that required quite a
bit of changes to get it right even
before VFX supervisor of Mars said that
he had jumped on the show Marvel had
already sent over the plates and told
him here's what we want for each shot
Christian was left thinking how are we
gonna pull this off some of their
requests had been things like hey rework
this camera move do this do that and if
it turned out that the plates didn't
work then Mars would have to recreate
the whole scene after and all from CG
now it's clear to see that they had
their work cut out for them and that was
just the start have you heard of vanity
AI it's pretty up-and-coming AI software
designed to do cosmetic fixes on an
actor quicker than ever before in the
past a visual effects supervisor might
have to wait for up to one week for just
a single scene to come back to them but
using vanity AI allows you to complete
cosmetic fixes on up to five shots a day
depending on the length of the shot and
how many frames is in it Mars developed
this technology while they were working
on the special effects for one division
where it was taking too long for artists
to paint over the tracking markers on
Paul betney's face for quantumania
vanity AI was mostly used on our teenage
character Cassie Lang just to freshen
her up and give her a more relatable
youthful look this saved our VFX artists
hours worth of time which they
definitely needed considering how much
work went into building Kang the
Conqueror Kang the Conqueror needed to
be a real threat he needed you need to
feel tactile like something the audience
could hold on to and so they had
Jonathan Majors step in to play the
physical man all while his suit and
Powers were mostly added in CGI Kang's
force fields and laser beams needed to
be added in after the fact as well as
his distinctive blue helmet behind the
scenes photos of Jonathan on set show
that he didn't do a whole lot of flying
after all instead posing on top of a big
blue box the VFX team would later
integrate this plate-based photography
with CGI to give us the scene we
recognize from the movie our artists
struggled to get the design of Kang's
suit just right not as much as they
struggled with veb maybe but even from
initial trailers to the final movie you
can see that Kang's suit has been filled
in with more details and that his
helmet's been given a sleeker more comic
accurate look how could you not love
them hello oh hi he was the surprise
breakout star of quantumania featuring
the voice of David desmulchin who's been
with the Ant-Man series from the very
beginning nice to meet you yeah nice to
meet you too but did you know that David
was still right there on the set the
entire time these hilarious behind the
scenes photos from the set show David
dressed in a gray suit as a stand-in for
beb and we suppose it's nice to know
that our actors actually had something
to work against NPC's modeling and
texture artists studied animals such as
jellyfish in order to get vet's
translucent pink skin right but
surprisingly that wasn't the part that
they struggled with the most that
distinction would have to go to web's
Expressions seeing as our artists who
are having a hard time getting Fab to
express his emotions without any holes
we imagine they must have been as glad
to have that change as Feb was I have
Marvel may have used some pretty
state-of-the-art technology in the
creation of quantumania but we have
disappointed to hear that their VFX team
wasn't happy with their working
conditions what did you think about the
special effects in the movie even
knowing that their team was working way
over time we'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure to let us know
down in the comment section